la imagen de varias estaciones en llamas
la noche del 18 de octubre se convirtió
en la representación del descontento en
chile lo que empezó como unas protestas
estudiantiles con respecto a las tarifas
de pasajes terminó siendo una crisis
social a la cual se sumió el país en
semanas de violentas manifestaciones
callejeras casi un año después el metro
de santiago reabrió las puertas de todas
sus estaciones este viernes el proceso
de reconstrucción de las estaciones de
metro que duró aproximadamente 11 meses
recordemos que fueron 118 de 136
estaciones que fueron destruidas de
alguna forma
y recibió una inversión final de 255
millones de dólares y requirió un
esfuerzo muy intenso de los trabajadores
de la empresa para los usuarios la
vuelta completa de operaciones del
ferrocarril metropolitano es un alivio
en una ciudad en la que viven más de 71
millones de personas
cerca
es muy grande
el verano facilita mucho a poco de
cumplirse un año la justicia aún no
aclara quién o quiénes quemaron el metro
de santiago el gobierno lo atribuyó
desde un principio a grupos criminales
organizados pero hasta ahora la
investigación judicial ha logrado
detener sólo a un puñado de personas
algunos pertenecientes a grupos de
barrasbravas quienes han relatado que
actuaron movidos por la efervescencia
social